i'm off the grid for august and surprise
surprise they're still coming for your
kids
how about one uh libs that tick tock did
where kids kindergarteners
kindergarteners what's that age five
kindergartners yeah six five six six
first grade yeah
uh sent home with a masturbation
assignment
what the masturbation assignment was to
find a private place in your home where
you can touch yourself without being
disturbed is that real real
real [ __ ] i might have retweeted that
and i'm saying what
masturbation assignment for
kindergartners i mean this kind of stuff
it's like shocked but not because i did
read this one thing where they were they
were talking about kids that were
pre-teens and they were describing like
different ways that people have sex
and i'm like i just don't necessarily
think that's your place and yeah i don't
it's a complex thing that i don't
necessarily want taught by someone who i
don't even know i don't know what you're
like i don't know what how are you gonna
say this are you gonna say this in a way
that's promoting a certain thing or what
are you gonna do because children are
very malleable and most people want to
be the ones other than the you know the
world itself but in terms of like
authority figures they're explaining
things you don't want someone explaining
things to your kid that you absolutely
don't agree with right or that you don't
think they're ready for you yes right
and you don't want to happen on your
timing you want it to be look i've had
some great teachers but i also had some
[ __ ] dummies some real dummies that
said some stupid [ __ ] to me you know
yeah i remember i mean a
teacher kicking me out of room telling
the class don't laugh because he's never
going to amount to anything oh wow like
mr rogan's never going to amount to
anything and i remember like why would
you say that to a [ __ ] eight-year-old
now did you internalize that is all of
this is this every your whole trajectory
now in your career is definitely
remember stick it to that teacher i'd be
like ha ha but it was me cracking a joke
in class but the the whole point is like
you shouldn't say that to kids if you're
a [ __ ] teacher you shouldn't say to a
kid you're never going to amount to
anything that's a crazy thing to say
that's messed up not to think about i
think i was 14. but it's not a thing
that you should say to a kid it's it's a
rude shitty thing and if you're an adult
and they just that's what they're going
to get from you
and that's crazy that's crazy talk and
that is a problem with
expressing any complex ideas that may
have a very nuanced
there's
there's nuance to all of those
conversations
and you you might not want this person
who's not that bright not that good at
expressing themselves and very biased to
explain something to your kid that's
going to cause an argument at home
because then the kid's going to bring
something up and you go like where did
you hear this from or to tell your kid
that you know what you don't have to
confide in your parents about that don't
tell your parents about this come to me
about these issues that's where the [ __ ]
gets crazy that is grooming behavior and
you can't even call it that anymore but
it is